what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to an
abba and preach video
titled why we think the red milk pill
community is necessary even with its
faults
before i begin do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and each and every one of
you helps
while you're at it bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily
videos i'm actually excited somebody
sent me this
on my instagram which if you guys want
to submit videos you already know go to
my instagram the links in the
description
um but i was excited because i actually
really like abbott
but i 100 understand that there's an
absolute need
today's topic i disagree with the red
pill community but i 100
understand that there's an absolute need
for it people often complain about like
the rhetoric that comes out of like the
manosphere or whatever and i understand
some of those because
i disagree with a lot of the sentiments
that they share she said what's that
sentiments because it's easy to say i
disagree with someone
when like that's such a broad group
obviously
you don't 100 agree with anyone i've
i've been called a blue pill and
purple appeal and whatever the term that
they have honestly i find the whole
matrix reference are there's different
colors of the
super cringey but it's 100 necessary and
i think one thing that people don't
understand
is that there's a lot of expectations
placed on men in regards to
uh the roles that they have to play in
society in regards to the roles that
they have to play within the dating
sphere
you know the idea that we have to
approach the idea we have to be the one
putting the foot forward and doing all
this stuff
that's actually one thing that i really
didn't realize
um when learning like about the
manosphere just how hard like a lot of
men have it
because i think as a girl when you're
like watching
the dating game you kind of only see it
from like different women's perspectives
so you only really
understand how easy it is for like the
top you know
percentage of men but you don't
understand like the struggles they have
to go through so i
i agree with what he's saying not saying
that women don't have the
responsibilities i'm just saying there's
a lot placed on us right
the big problem is that we have zero
resources in the mainstream
to know how to do these things we don't
learn it from our parents because our
parents oftentimes don't know what the
we don't learn at school and our friends
are just as clueless as we are so what
ends up happening is that we look
towards media
but the thing is men don't have shows
like the view
men don't have shows like women do where
they get to learn all the next beauty
tips and have all their problems
constantly talked about other than
sports shows
and so what ends up happening is that
men turn
towards i would agree um
like to me women just tend to be more
verbal
and complain more would you agree with
that or disagree that's just like
alternative media joe rogan joe organ is
a perfect example of that
i love joe rogan if i could meet he's
one of the like
five people that if i could be i blew up
but yo when he was just back
it was just a bunch of guys watching him
all the time because it's like the first
time that they watched someone
speaking long form about that they were
going through i'm talking back in 2013
when this podcast was like
yeah set up right i used to watch it
back then i was like oh okay cool
one thing i've learned like just come to
realize with myself is like i remember
when we first started doing videos i
used to be like way more angry about a
lot of stuff right
and looking back now kind of i used to
ask myself why i was so angry covering
some of these topics
and it dawned on me that for so long
i've been having lived experiences with
women
that were either negative or super toxic
and
when i would bring this up to people
around me they would gaslight me or
they'd be like well as a man that's not
a real thing so
right whether it be being hit whether it
be like women doing weird stuff
women hit him saying terrible things and
like just the the lack of accountability
that society seems to place on women in
those kind of scenarios
threw me for a loop i couldn't believe
it and so i used to build up a certain
level of resentment to the idea like
they can just get away with this
okay this is something that i've noticed
in different like conversations with
like different guys in my life like i
think feminism
was necessary and it was a reaction to
maybe
women not having a lot of choice in
career women
um you know having being forced on some
level to stay with their husbands
even if they didn't want to because um
just like what else were they gonna do
so i understand why that happened but
like to me that red pill
is the reaction because the feminist
movement went
too far and so now women aren't being
held accountable for their actions like
that makes sense to me
and we just constantly reinforce these
ideas right and i would look towards
media and i would watch
you know shows like uh i'm pretty sure
it's the view i can't remember what it
was but a girl just talking about
i hate the video like cutting off a
dude's penis and throwing in a garbage
dispenser and everyone laughs and claps
i don't know the circumstances i don't
know why he filed for divorce i don't
know
what was going on between them however
i do think it's quite fabulous i mean
[Applause]
i mean can you just imagine that thing
whizzing around the disposal
it's like hysterical but however i think
i would have just
depending on why she cut it off i mean
it does depend on the reasons why
does it yes
she's on the tv for the next couple like
imagine a dude getting
on a round table and everyone laughing
about a girl's like pieces getting cut
off down there
never what happened yeah yeah no that's
true
oh my god that grossed me out even
because even if a girl cheated what if a
guy like cut off her boobs
that would they would look at her as
crazy
and i would constantly see this
reinforcing media where women could
touch dudes grope them do whatever they
want where they can
hit dudes and it's very popular and it's
fine but then
anything that happens to us we're just
supposed to enjoy it because we're men
and
over time i used to get annoyed with
like a lot of the stuff that was just
commonplace and
you know the crazy thing is i will say
though as a caveat to that just like if
a woman
keeps ending up with a guy that's
cheating she has to look inside and say
hey
why do i keep attracting the same type
of guy
if a guy keeps attracting women that are
abusive
like he it's really his job to look
inside to say why do i keep putting up
with this behavior
because you don't have to you choose who
you date these women weren't
bad people they weren't people that were
like extremely malicious
but they're raising an environment
that's told them this kind of stuff is
acceptable
so you're talking about the norm or even
the men are trash
thing like i used to hear that all the
time and even believe it
at one point in my life um like the men
are trash men are trash men are trash
and you really have to look inside
and say like why do i think this who am
i choosing because
like do you feel that way about your
father your brother you know
and so forth i started doing these
videos and i started venting all that
pent up resentment all that anger
coming out i could feel it
all of it just for a period i actually
went to the red pill stuff
i was watching that i think probably
from the ages of like 18 to 25 like
you know because as a young man you're
told you have to do the approach you get
to do all this stuff right
mom i don't know what i'm doing it's
awkward i go up to these ladies and
heart rejections and self-esteem so i'm
like yo i need help so what did i do
pick-up artist i read the book the game
i watched
keys to the vip which is oddly enough a
show that was
shut down just for teaching dudes game
right i would watch all these stuff
and i was like cool i'm learning i'm
learning but they also had some toxic
ideas terrible ideas
but i'm like i have no alternative where
else am i going to learn right who's
talking about it who
right nobody then i go on youtube find
joe rogan i find
a couple of other red pill folks i'm
like oh okay i'm learning some stuff
but i'm indoctrinating this thing you
know by the time i start 24 25 so i
realized some of this stuff is bad and i
took myself
from that environment but i also
recognized it filled the void in my life
that no
i'd like to hear if that stuff actually
helped him with like
game so one else was able to fill there
are no resources
to teach young men these skills none
whatsoever but we expect them to be good
at it
it's not only that is
they expect all these men to do all
these things
and the price for failure is so big
the price of failure not only for your
self-esteem
but just you being labeled a creep it
cost a lot
yeah it's really the cost as well about
it i i realized i mean one of my friend
realized how much the cost was
that whenever she was talking that oh
yeah man i was at the i was at the
pharmacy
and i saw my boyfriend so i tap it on
the ass and it was not my boyfriend and
i'm like oops and then i left and my
boyfriend was there and we all laughed
and i was like
if i think i right if a if a girl did a
guy did that he would be in a lot of
trouble but my girlfriend turned
in a public environment i'm gonna make
sure it's my girlfriend i can't just
because i cannot afford
as a man as a black man to just
tap the booty of just some random girl
and be like sorry yeah because the cost
of that
is potentially bigger than just hey
oops you know jordan peterson comes on
the scene
i love jordan peterson they're they're
talking about all my favorite youtubers
he says to men clean your room and he
turns into this huge sensation
and okay jordan peterson i know mostly
guys watch him but i swear he
changed my life i i read that book that
that's from
and it actually made me stop like
drinking a lot of people just don't
understand especially women they're like
what is so poignant about this
and i'm like do you not recognize that
men were so much in need
of that kind of stuff about telling them
to take responsibility for their own
lives and
how to do it that they turned to just
even that simple piece of advice became
so important do not understand that
there's such a need for dudes to have
their issues just
it's not to say that women don't deal
with a lot of terrible stuff and i agree
with you
if you want to say that you are more
disadvantaged i would probably agree
with you
but people don't live on a macro scale
i do not live as a black man thinking
about all black people all the time i'm
thinking about my personal experiences
i'm walking through life
so when you go up to a man and you say
your opinions are invalid
and your issues aren't valid because
women suffer more well as an in
on a macro scale i could understand what
you're trying to say
but on a micro scale which is how most
people simulate their experiences
i'm like well you're just telling me i
don't matter yeah and they would start
to say that men really don't especially
like white men don't have a right to be
upset about anything like it would go i
remember that media like a couple years
ago it would go
pretty far especially like on twitter
and stuff you're telling me my problems
don't matter
so then i'm going to turn away from you
right and then just love to jump in
they'll be like we as a community have
created environments where men stop
lying
first off when you go in those
environments they start looking at you
like uh you better keep quiet say only
the right things and say the right way
that's not inviting that's not appealing
so that men have turned towards men's
circles
to find people who understand them and
speak the way that they do
and resonate with their problems so when
you sit there from afar you're like man
this reputable community is trash
well great i think it's great that you
keep saying that but here's the problem
what's the alternative we can't be on tv
talking about our problems because
nobody cares i will get cancelled
i've seen so many men's dude when i was
from the early 2000s to like mid-2010
right
just destroyed and taken off the air
because they were toxic and unacceptable
right
i mean even honestly like chris harrison
but women's tv shows they can go on for
years they can say the crazy stuff
yeah they can
they say like the view they say some
crazy stuff the most foul things fine
for television
but we have no spaces like that yeah you
didn't present
no alternative i don't believe that it
was for them to present them
but when because they have their own
issues but when others presented
other alternatives for other people they
got shut down
it's not so much it was like it's like
it was your job to present something
other no it's like asking for men to
present alternatives for women
no we don't know the reality and you are
better placed to know that
wait what are you talking about derek
jackson
sure but because derek jackson
happened and was in line with what
you're saying you let him slide
right but other people you shut that
down
real quick i don't think that it's for
you to give other alternatives
but whenever that alternative i don't
think it matters
who is saying the message like honestly
it's the question i ask is is the
message
true i don't even if they're talking
about women's issues or women's
like stuff that's regards to women i
don't care if a guy talks about it
it's just is it true it's what he's
saying correct it happens
you shut it down and you cancel it and
then it just gets worse
what you do by doing and they also the
what by doing what they're doing they
take out
the ability to be wrong like i've said
stuff
at some point that probably wasn't
correct or wasn't right
and people can say things that are
incorrect and go back on it later like
that's what i don't like about like
cancel culture that is that you create
martyrs
and then they get to evolve and develop
every time
jordan peterson was getting they tried
to cancel them or they tried to do
something like that or they try to shut
them down
she gained more power and more people
every time you do that
you're doing a disservice to your own
self yep but whatever
so listen whether you're a woman
whatever like listen it behooves you to
acknowledge the fact that men deal with
problems
all right it does not take away from
your issues it does not mean that you're
invalidated but men are struggling and
suffering from certain things and it's a
hard
there's a hard knock life out there you
know just because we're not as vocal
about it as you guys are we don't talk
about it the same way you do
doesn't mean it's not there it doesn't
mean it's not there even this channel
even this channel all right i don't
think you'd throw us in the red pill
area
but you know we definitely have some
ideas that congregate with them as well
right even this channel do you not
recognize why we got so popular so fast
aside from the fact that we got a decent
commentary
part of it is we filled the void so yeah
as far as like the red pill stuff and
and this whole manuscript and stuff like
that men need their outlets and i'm not
saying it's this is the most positive
one i'm not saying but until there's a
until there's resources to tell men how
to do this stuff effectively do it well
until women in society in general starts
and
stops invalidating what men go through
right we're not going to fix these
issues
we're just not sure we're just not so
it's it's it's a two thing it's a
two-part thing it's not getting soft
here's why i disagree i think men for
the first time are like venting
on a loud platform and very directly and
well and the world's getting better guys
like in general
are we moving towards more equality
or less equality like i mean this is
definitely a problem
definitely an issue but when you look at
the world as a whole
like things are getting better so
i i think a lot of these like movements
are like reactionary so like
feminism was reactionary to you know
like women not having career choices not
having the ability to leave a marriage
etc
etc
feminism came in took it too far and
then another movement
comes in and takes it too far as well i
mean
yeah that's like but you know let me
know in the comments if i'm if i'm wrong
because i could be
just my analysis they've been holding it
in for so long
that some of it's very toxic so get it
out
get it all out and then after you've
chilled out we've calmed down and then
you know some of this has taken some
time
that we could breathe and like talk
about it some more and get deeper in
there
right because a lot of these problems
are super valid you know
like i said but you cannot discount all
of it they just burp
so i've been there um that was my
thoughts about the red pill community
people been asking me about that for a
while
i'm glad i went through that phase
because it helped me out and i'm glad i
started doing these videos because i got
to vent that
out because i'm telling you i was made
to feel crazy my whole life
even by other men the other man was like
you're supposed to bear it i'm like why
are we
tolerating this i would never think of
like doing that to somebody else but we
as men
and everyone just made me think like yo
it's not important i'm like no this is
real it's real and when you guys
make people feel like their things are
their problems are not real they become
angry
because their problems on the inside
just fester
because people just want to feel heard
i've heard someone say that and it's
really true like a lot of times
when i'm mad or i'm frustrated i don't
this sounds bad but sometimes i don't
even want a solution i just want to feel
like somebody understands my problem
i mean i want a solution too but you
guys get what i'm saying i still get it
sometimes you know sometimes i
i talk about these problems and i can
start to
feel again the issues that i had back
then
and it kind of comes out of me and i'm
just like where's this coming from like
i still i still need more time to get it
all out so yeah once again
i'll just say this to end ladies i
recognize
i'll have real problems and i'll never
stop you know try to defend y'all from
those issues
i would like to also add one caveat a
lot of times
the mental like feeling of like people
saying you can't talk can't
like whatever it's all online and i'm
not saying it doesn't exist in real life
it does too
but i've noticed that a lot of issues go
away when i think about it in my real
life life with the people that i talk to
like a good friend of mine or a good
like someone that i've been friends with
for a while that i came with
with a problem wouldn't tell me i can't
have that problem
but let me know if that's different for
men um than it is for women because
obviously things are different [ __ ]
i want to help you know but i think
there has to be room for men to be able
to
deal with those issues without everyone
trying to interfere because we just
don't have outlets
not the way y'all do not the way y'all
do and if you don't believe me try to
find
try to find outlets on mainstream media
for men to talk about their stuff
candidly you won't you know where we
turn to
podcasts
that's what it is that's why there's a
there's a lot more men podcast than
women that's how this
meme why do man why do men don't deal
with the issues
and but but instead they just do
podcasts because that's the outlet
that's what we can talk it out yeah
podcast is very niche
it's very niche so if it's niche i can
find a group of
niche people that go through the same
that i'm going
and it's free i'm not going to be you
know i got less chances of less chances
of being cancelled
so that's why they do it yeah yeah so
that's my thoughts on this topic
okay yeah that was really interesting um
i definitely agree with
i forget which one's album which one's
pretty i think abba's the taller one
um but what he was saying about how
like men don't always have an outlet to
like talk and
what he was saying how women like get
away with stuff i definitely agree with
all that
let me know in the comments if you agree
or you disagree
and do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
let me know in the comments what video i
should react to
next time